hi my name is Samuel legs and I'm really
hope to spend a couple of days with you
next month for the property investors
crash course if you're already booked on
congratulations if you're not I just
cover a few things that we're going to
be learning so of course we're covering
HMOs how to source HMOs where you can
retire off just three deals we're gonna
be covering the lease option agreements
joint ventures raising finance
properties without having any money
which is how I built of a large part of
myself olio from the age of 18 but a
couple of really interesting parts that
we're gonna be covering which are very
packed to 2017 one is the new tax
changes and all the changes that are
coming in how they're not actually a
disadvantage to you but if you're smart
they'll be an advantage too
I paid the zeroes snap cheated the tax
changes won't
benefits
we're gonna be covering all work and I'm
gonna be explaining why now is the best
time to be investing in property
another thing is systemization I mean
many of you know if you follow me on
Facebook but most of last year we spent
abroad or travel in California Africa
Asia right now we've been in Devon for a
few days we're now in Wales it doesn't
matter where our properties are and
where we are what matters is the systems
in place so I'm going to be teaching you
how you can set up systems Road doesn't
matter where you buy it doesn't matter
where you are in the world it matters
about your systems so give me a
brilliant couple days loads of content
loads of fun loads of learning we've
currently got over 150 people booked on
people travelling from all over the
world as far as Australia Greece we've
got about six spaces left that we will
be closing all bookings in the next few
hours so if you're serious about
property versus
if you want to become financially free
with me and some of the team that vote
on it now at this ridiculous silly price
that we have god bless you see you next
month